اهلا بكم الى مرز الاخبار من الجزيره
تعاهد قاده مجموعه الدول السبعه الصناعيه
الكبرى بتزويد اوكرانيا بانظمه وقدرات
للدفاع الجوي وبحث قاده المجموعه في
اجتماع عبر التقنيه الفيديو بمشاركه
الرئيس الاوكراني امكانيه الفردي عقوبه
اكثر صرامه على روسيا وتقديم مزيد من
الدعم
خارجيه الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي في اجتماع
لهم بروكسل على تخصص اكثر من مليارات يورو
لدعم عسكريا واقل مفاوض سياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد
انها خلافاتنا حاله دون فرض حزمه تاسعه من
العقوبات على روسيا
ياتيني ذلك في وقت يتواصل فيه القصف
الروسي شرقيه اوكرانيا وفي جنوبها كما
افادت مراسله الجزيره ان القصف الصاروخيه
الاوكراني تجدد على وسط مدينه دنيت
شيع اهالي مدينه جنين الفتاه جنى زكارنه
التي استشهدت امس برصاص الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي واوضحت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
ان الفتاه اصيبت برصاصه في الراس اطلقها
جنود الاحتلال خلال اقتحامهم من طاقه
البيادر بمدينه جنين
من جانبه عربه وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
بينيكانس عن اسفه لمقتل جنه زكارنه وقال
ان التحقيقا قد فتح للوقوف على ملابسات ما
جرى
وان كانت قوات الاحتلال اعتقلت ثمانيه عشر
فلسطينيا في مناطق متفرقه من الضفه
الغربيه منها بيت لحم وجنين والخليل
ونابلس رام الله فضلا عن القدس المحتله
حمل اتحاد الشغل في تونس رئيس الجمهوريه
نتائج ما سماها سياسه التعنت والانسداد
وحذر الحكومه من الاستمرار فيما وصفها
بسياسه الارتجال وانعدام الكفاءه في
مجابهه الازمه واقل الامين العام للاتحاد
نور الدين
تعيش وما وصفه بمنعرج خطير ودعا الرئيس
للقيام بخطوات الى الوراء من اجل الوحده
الوطنيه
من جانبه والجها سعيد انتقادات للمعارضه
متهمه اياها بعقد تحالفات مع الخارج
وبالسعي وراء السلطه وبيعدم
المبالاتي بمطالب التونسيين
تفاقم التوتر في شمال كسوفو بين الاقليه
الصربيه والسلطات عقبه تبادل الاطلاق
النار مع شرطه الاقليم بعد اعتقال الشرطي
صربيا سابقا وحضر الاتحاد الاوروبي ومن
انها هجمات محتمله على البعثه الاوروبيه
كما حضرتها الرئاسه الروسيه من مواجهه
المفتوحه واتهمت الدول الاوروبيه
والولايات المتحده بالتواطئ وحملتهم
مسؤوليه التدهور الامني
في المقابل دعت واشنطن الى ضبط النفس
واتخاذ اجراءات فوريه لتهدئه الموقف
والامتناعي عن الاعمال الاستفزازيه
اشكركم على متابعه الموجزه لما كنتم طابت
اوقاتكم بكل